hey guys just here to play some video  games hope you enjoy all right face  reveal time you guys earned it I know  I'm ugly you know that clip of me  screaming at a seven-year-old is gaining  some traction which is pretty cool come  on Chad show me those twitch primes time  to do an ironic hot tub stream time to  do an outdoor stream just kidding I  don't go outside time to share my  political opinions  oh I'm trending on Twitter those very  public things I stated the other day are  in no way representative of my actual  political beliefs even though I've been  stating them for years we just did our  biggest sub goal wow I wish I could get  canceled every week Gamers we've had a  wild ride but I think it's time for it  to end because we're moving to YouTube I  will be streaming on YouTube now  because they gave me a lot of money